[Music]
don't take it from us
take it from the man himself robert
downey jr in 2008 the marvel legend
turned to elon musk when he needed help
getting into character for tony stark
musk's enthusiastic embrace of
technology for technology's sake
and his desire to push the limits of
what is possible makes him the closest
thing to iron man will ever get
of course stark deals in weapons
technology and musk is all about
automobiles and space travel
but they both have a passion for
sustainable and renewable energy
and let's face it they pretty much have
the same sense of humor
so could he make the iron man suits well
isn't that the billion dollar question
but you'll have to stick around to the
end to find that answer in the meantime
we're going to look at everything that
tesla and spacex founder is up to
and what makes him so much like the
genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist
take that off what are you genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist
before we dive in make sure to hit the
subscribe button and ring the bell icon
so you're notified every time we upload
a new video to say that the billionaire
tech entrepreneur is a busy man would be
a gross understatement
elon musk is the head of several
companies each of which has some big
plans for the future
for electric vehicles and renewable
energy solutions he has
tesla to give mankind a shot at becoming
an interplanetary species
he's got spacex to transform
transportation on earth itself
he's working with the boring company and
he is also working with them to build
tunnels and temporary habitats on mars
for the early settlers for the
conscientious development of artificial
intelligence
he's funding and working with openai and
if that wasn't enough for you
he is also working on augmenting the
capability of the human brain with
neural link
let's start with tesla one of two
companies taking up the majority of his
time
according to tesla's timeline the
refreshed model s plaid plus with a new
cockpit is due to arrive later this year
it will cost around 139 thousand dollars
with 1100 horsepower and go from zero to
60 miles per hour
in under two seconds and what of the
range it will go an estimated 520 miles
on a single charge according to them
electric cars are nowhere near what tony
stark makes but his dad did take a crack
at making the hover car once but this
next tesla vehicle
is a little closer to what stark
industries might offer
the version meant available the military
is essentially the next humvee
and it comes with a roof mounted machine
gun and a deployable drone
another design for the truck turns it
into an armored tank for combat
complete with a 360 degree tank gun yep
this is more stark's language
there are other versions of the cyber
truck of course the goal of tesla
developing the vehicle is to provide a
sustainable energy substitute for the
trucks currently in use
there will be four versions of the cyber
truck plant apocalypse
next humvee tank and quiet scout now
tesla is known to push the production
timelines
while we hope the cyber truck arrives
this year none of us here would be
surprised
if it didn't hit the roads in 2021
especially since tesla is also working
on the upcoming gigafactory in texas the
one that's supposed to build the cyber
trucks they're pushing to complete at
least a part of it by may 2021 so they
can start on production
though how well that will go we aren't
sure but once complete the gigafactory
will be tesla's first plant built from
the ground up in america their current
factory in california used to be a
general motors and toyota joint venture
project
the texas facility will also increase
production capabilities
currently every single vehicle tesla
builds and sells in america comes out of
california
shifting some of the manufacturing
burden to a new facility will take some
of the pressure off but that doesn't
mean the pressure on elon musk gets any
lighter
just like stark spends too much time
with the machines in his lab
so does musk his other venture spacex
has gained worldwide attention
it's the only private company capable of
returning a spacecraft from lower earth
orbit
and last year it became the only private
company to place humans on the
international space station
in the long term elon musk wants to
place one million people on mars by 2050
build a freeway to the planet and also
create underground habitats for the
first settlers on the red planet as if
that wasn't enough
he is also planning missions to
enceladus a saturnian moon
europa and a fuel depot on pluto among
other things
but sticking to the mars mission for now
an uncrewed starship rocket is set to
launch in 2024
settling on mars cannot happen without
funding and though elon musk may be the
richest man in the world
paying out of pocket is not possible
with a project of this size
so he's funding his mission with another
project starlink
starlink aims to bring high-speed online
access to those in rural hard-to-reach
locations
the first two starlink satellites tintin
a and b
were launched into orbit in february
2018. by august of 2020
they had successfully deployed 600
satellites 200
shy of creating a fully functional
system the company plans to provide near
global coverage by the end of 2021.
alongside this musk is working on a
de-orbit plan
which outlines how spacex is going to
deal with all of the space debris from
deteriorating satellites
but if space travel is in your jam and
you just want to get to work
there may be an easier way coming soon
again thanks to elon musk
his hyperloop project would cut down
long journeys by transporting you at
speeds
of 700 miles per hour just to give you
some context
the fastest roller coaster in the world
which is in ferrari world abu dhabi
travels at 149 miles per hour you would
travel in a low pressure tube
inside a pod-like capsule supported by
air and powered by magnetic
linear acceleration that's just a lot of
jargon to say
you'll be hovering over the rails and
going super fast now iron man hasn't
done much for public transport in new
york
but the helicarriers which can carry
people to safety and transport cargo
might count but if that isn't your cup
of tea either musk has another way you
can avoid rush hour he has a project
with the boring company to dig a tunnel
underground so electric cars can skate
by and beat traffic the idea is to solve
the problem of traffic by going 3d
elevated highways and interchanges are
disruptive to build and take up valuable
space in a city where land is already
scarce
their tunneling networks will allow you
to zoom past traffic above ground
that is as long as you drive a tesla or
any other electric vehicle
you don't want to be stuck here driving
a combustion engine car this facility
already exists under the las vegas
convention center it reduces a 45 minute
walk to two minutes by placing
passengers in tesla vehicles
that go 34 miles an hour but of course
it won't stop there
the ambition is to have complex tunnel
systems underneath entire cities
the lvcc loop could eventually be
connected to a more extensive loop
system under las vegas
so it's pretty simple get an electric
car use the underground tunnel that
helps you beat traffic
pretty good incentive right here's
another one musk also heads solarcity
corporation
which develops and sells solar panels
and solar roof tiles
they now rent out their solar panels to
customers at a mere 50
a month as an incentive to boost
residential solar deployments
but he doesn't want it to end there much
like his fictional counterpart
musk wants everybody to have clean
energy that doesn't harm the environment
enter the power wall a home battery unit
that will power your home and that can
be controlled by your phone from
anywhere it stores energy
detects outages and becomes a primary
energy source when the grid is down
and of course it reduces your carbon
footprint not enough
well he's in the healthcare industry too
neuralink which musk launched in 2016
aims to plant a computer chip in the
human brain using a robot surgeon
it will connect the brain to the digital
world starting with your smartphone
unlike tony stark elon musk isn't going
to need jarvis or friday to help once
neural link is up and running because
the resulting computing power will allow
humans to be competitive with developing
ai
in the short term his plans are to use
the chip to solve all ailments and
injuries relating to the brain
from depression and anxiety to dementia
and paralysis
sure iron man managed to stop ultron but
musk plans to never give it the chance
to rise in the first place
open ai's mission is to ensure that when
artificial intelligence inevitably
becomes smarter and stronger than the
human race
that it benefits humanity and doesn't
you know eradicate us
so technically yeah if you wanted to
musk could find a way to create the iron
man suit but will he
probably not he has enough on his plate
besides
we don't have the technology to build an
arc reactor or any such constant power
source as powerful as starks
even if we could it certainly wouldn't
sit in such a tiny disc
but elon musk doesn't require a suit
anyway he's already saving the world
with his advancements in tech
but maybe he'll consider it as a
retirement project
after all stark figured out time travel
when he was in retirement
we'll just have to see but what do you
think let us know in the comments below
if you enjoyed the video
hit the like button and check out more
like this on the simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time